foreign
ly the development team behind the
division Resurgence opened up a limited
time test server in Europe while I'm
about as far away as you can get from
Europe they reached out to me and gave
me a code anyway unfortunately I was
unable to find a device that was
compatible at this stage so I couldn't
participate however this is where my
good friend abrex comes in he too was
invited and has kindly provided some
footage for me to use now I know he
didn't do it for this reason but I'm
going to shout him out anyway if you've
been a subscriber of this channel for a
while you should recognize his name as
he is only one of a handful of division
creators that I'll shout out
we've known each other since the later
stages of the division one before either
of us were really doing too much in the
way of content creation
if you're new here please go and check
out his channel he has quality
well-researched content without the
oversensationalism and clickbait that
you may find elsewhere
I'll leave a link in the description
[Applause]
our own greed did Us in
before we knew it the dollar flew spread
like wildfire
a few weeks
that's how long it took for a
civilization to collapse
[Music]
[Applause]
of New York has asked for federal help
as city services are collapsing
Manhattan was being torn apart
so they locked it down
or tried
ready too late
the government is resorting to drastic
measures to tackle the crisis that is
why the president today has decided to
invoke directive 51. so they finally
activated us
the Strategic Homeland division
an elite group of embedded agents
we are the last line of defense
and we will give our lives to save what
remains
foreign
the game starts immediately after the
opening cinematic with the player
character being activated as a first
wave agent and on that note extra points
from me from beginning the game with a
cat there is already tons of dogs and
games I'm glad to see our feline
overlords being featured
after being activated we are contacted
by Astrid Maya the acting section chief
for Laura Manhattan
she gives a rundown of the current
situation and tells us to meet up with
agent Kelly and rescue a VIP Angela Chan
we find them both at the Spring Blossom
Restaurant but she is refusing to leave
without her people
the agents agree to help all of them and
escort them to a nearby checkpoint
the agents move out ahead to clear a
path and make sure that it is safe for
civilians the plan is to meet up with
the jtf at the Manhattan Bridge
checkpoint however Maya releases an
update to all agents over the comms
to all agents be advised that the jtf
has lost control of several checkpoints
across Midtown we now have bad guys
operating with impunity in some areas
be careful
the agents called through to Chang
telling you that the path between them
is clear
once at the checkpoint agent Kelly
suddenly receives a call from a doctor
O'Neill at the Trinity Church field
hospital they are being overrun and need
help
grabbing a helicopter and a handful of
jtf officers the agents make their way
over there
flying above the buildings it was easy
to see the true damage to the city due
to the collapse
suddenly a rocket is fired at them from
one of the buildings below and then
another
the second Clips them sending them into
a spin but as the agents are now close
enough to the building they make a jump
and land on the roof as the helicopter
loses control crashing into the
buildings below
fighting their way through they come
across a heavily wounded jdf officer
he informs them that the hostiles had
overrun them and had taken all of their
support weapons heavy weapons
a mistake by the jtf why would they
bring these into the city the enemy is
now heavily armed
Maya asked the jtf commander about these
weapons but the order to bring them in
didn't come from him
the hostiles were headed to the stock
exchange and as it turns out this is the
fastest way to Trinity Church so the
agents will be meeting up with them to
reclaim these weapons
while clearing out the stock exchange a
jtf officer releases a call over the
radio
Trinity Church has fallen and people are
being taken as hostages
by the time they get there the hostels
are gone but have taken some of the
people with them including Dr O'Neill
they don't know where they're headed
just that they're being led by a man or
Jax
an echo outside the church reveals
they're headed to Liberty Island
all right
we go shut up Let the nurses go you only
need me
best keep your mouth shut doc you want
to keep your teeth where to next boss
Liberty Island
plenty of supplies there what about Carl
[ __ ] him I won't stand for tardiness
true that the statue has a restaurant
and a head no there isn't you dumb
bastard it's a small [ __ ] head it
can't be smaller than your dick
knock it off we gotta move
and a heavy fire the agents managed to
land on the island
a hostile reveals that Jacks had taken
all the hostages to the Statue he has
his men loading supplies onto the ferry
and is planning to blow up the island
once he leaves
the agents would find the hostages
locked in a room behind a door that has
been rigged to blow if anyone opened it
they defused the bomb and let them free
including Dr O'Neill
next the agents head after Jax before he
is able to leave the island
on the dock and in the ferry they catch
up with them after stopping him here's
one more gift as he blows up the theory
using a remote detonator
[Music]
and that is where the footage ends being
a test server we're only getting a small
taste of the story and we can see that
by the fact that the agent has only made
it up to level three or four
but this is looking like it could play
out similar to how the division one did
with us completing a number of smaller
tasks towards the much larger story that
has been played out in the background
I've said this before I'm not a mobile
gamer by any means and I know that this
isn't what a lot of people are after but
I'm legitimately looking forward to this
I certainly don't plan on playing this
like a typical mobile game though I will
100 be using a controller or better yet
an emulator on PC remember the teams
working on this have absolutely no
impact on the other games these are
completely different Talent pools
But like everyone else I too would like
more content for the division 2 or even
a division three but for now this is
looking good to supplement the
increasing gaps between content drops in
the main game
plus if the Resurgence team is able to
keep their plan of releasing updates
every three months there's going to be a
lot to keep up with
I'm someone who loves the division
universe and the story behind it maybe
more than I like the game some days so
anything that continues to feed into it
whether it be games novels audiobooks or
even Comics to a lesser extent I'm all
for it
even though we've really only seen a
small snippet of what the resurgent
story is like so far there is already
more information coming through around
what it was like before the jtf had
completely lost control and pulled out
of the area so I'm looking forward to
learning more about the space within the
overall timeline
a big thank you again to abrex and
extremist Moss extremely remedia
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]